a Baltimore police officer resigned
after a disturbing video surfaced of him
beating a man on the street cell phone
video captured the unidentified officer
repeatedly hitting the Shawn Maguire
Saturday the second officer in the video
was placed on administrative duties
Errol Barnett is outside police
headquarters Errol good morning good
morning yeah that video difficult to
watch getting everyone's attention here
to show mcruiz attorney tells CBS News
his client is in a lot of pain suffering
from a fractured jaw and multiple
fractured ribs but what's key is what
led up to the incident with video at the
beginning appears to show Magritte and
the officer in question arguing before
it turns violent the punches seem to
come without warning
Deshawn McGraw is repeatedly hit in the
head and body by the unnamed officer who
continues to throw punches tackling
McGraw and pinning him to the ground
interim Baltimore Police Commissioner
Garry Tuggle suspended the officer
immediately saying in a statement he was
deeply disturbed by the video adding
officers have a responsibility and duty
to control their emotions in the most
stressful of situations
Maria's attorney Warren Brown says the
officer who had been on the force for
just over a year tried to provoke his
client he claims the officer arrested
McGriff back in June for allegedly
assaulting him a charge mcgrae is
fighting and cool people like that
destroy the progress to reconcile the
differences between the community and
the police department the Baltimore
Police Department has faced a number of
allegations of police brutality and
fabricating evidence in recent years in
January and officer was indicted after
his body camera appeared to show him
planting drugs at the scene of a bust
and in 2015 the city faced a series of
protests following the death of Freddie
gray
who was injured in police custody and
later died
Brown says the policing problems cross
racial lines it's really not why do
black is blue is this the uniform that
they wear and I think they take
advantage of that uniform they take
advantage of the powers that have been
given
McGrew also says the mayor the interim
police commissioner and the state's
attorney's offices all reached out to
him on the day of the incident and he
has this sense but they do want to send
a message that this type of behavior is
unacceptable now we have reached out to
the Baltimore Police Union for comment
on behalf of the officers involved and
we've yet to hear back
bianna that's disturbing video rail
thank you that video is hard to watch it
is